The 2010s saw Hollywood blockbusters making
bank like never before.
It was a decade of Disney dominance and franchise
fever, where pretty much every top-earner
was a sequel to a previous movie — usually
one involving a lightsaber or an infinity
stone.
But exactly which movies won out in each year?
Disney kicked off its best-ever decade with
the third film in the franchise that changed
animation forever: Toy Story 3.
The original Toy Story launched the series,
made Pixar a household name, and became the
biggest grosser of 1995.
Toy Story 2 came out four years later, and
earned even more than its predecessor.
With results like that, a third film seemed
like a no brainer.
But it would be a whole 11 years before Pixar
returned to the series.
While Pixar made billions in the interim,
animation fans were still desperate to see
the "conclusion" to the original Pixar series.
And they got their wish when Toy Story 3 opened
in 2010.
It was worth the wait, too, as the film earned
an amazing 98% Tomatometer score, with a stellar
box office performance to match.
It earned $415 domestically and more than
$1 billion worldwide, making Toy Story 3 the
highest-grossing movie released in 2010.
Here's a catch for you, though — it wasn't
actually the movie to earn the most money
in 2010.
That honor went to Avatar, which was released
in late 2009 — but made $466 million domestically
in the year that followed.
Of course, while Toy Story 3 seemed like the
perfect conclusion to the trilogy, everyone
knows by now that you just can't keep a billion-dollar
franchise down.
Toy Story 4 was released in 2019, and managed
to outperform its predecessor with a worldwide
take of $1.07 billion.
"To infinity…"
"And beyond."
Harry Potter is big business at the box office.
The franchise, consisting of the seven Harry
Potter films and the two Fantastic Beasts
prequels, has totalled more than $2.7 billion
domestically and nearly $9.2 billion worldwide.
The high point in the franchise came at the
very end of its first run with 2011's Harry
Potter and The Deathly Hallows Part II.
Deathly Hallows Part II was pitched as the
epic conclusion to the eight-film saga that
had begun ten years before with Harry Potter
& The Sorcerer's Stone a movie that had itself
been the highest-grossing movie of 2001.
Surprisingly, the Harry Potter series wouldn't
hit numbers like that again until this final
installment.
Anticipation for the movie was at a fever
pitch right before release, so much so that
Deathly Hallows Part II set a then-opening
weekend record of $169 million, on its way
to a total domestic gross of $381 million
and a worldwide gross of $1.3 billion.
All in all, it was a good year to be a boy
wizard.
But his reign at the top would be short lived.
It's hard to believe now, but Marvel's grand
experiment of a shared cinematic universe
once had an uncertain future at the box office.
Iron Man exceeded all expectations when it
opened in 2008, taking a B-level comic book
character and giving him a movie that earned
$318 million domestically and $585 million
worldwide.
"Is it better to be feared or respected?
I saw, is it too much to ask for both?"
However, the ensuing MCU films weren't quite
as successful.
The Incredible Hulk bombed in 2008 with $134
million domestic and $263 million worldwide,
only barely managing to make back its own
budget.
While Thor and Captain America: The First
Avenger fared better in 2011, none of these
films really screamed "biggest blockbuster
franchise ever."
If anything, The Avengers felt like it might
be little more than "Iron Man & Friends."
But movie history had other plans.
The Avengers set a then-opening weekend record
of $207 million, becoming the first movie
to open with more than $200 million, and soon
ended up with $623 million domestic and $1.5
billion worldwide total.
But as amazing as these numbers were, The
Avengers' greatest achievement was giving
the Marvel Cinematic Universe the kick in
the tights it needed to become a $22.5 billion
powerhouse.
$22.5 billion and counting, that is.
Disney may have dominated the decade, but
in 2013 the biggest hit at the domestic box
office came from a much smaller film studio:
Lionsgate.
The studio had previously scored a major coup
when it won the rights to Suzanne Collins'
wildly popular novel series The Hunger Games.
The first film launched the franchise in a
big way, earning $152 million in its opening
weekend, on its way to $408 million domestic
and $694 million worldwide.
Its sequel, The Hunger Games: Catching Fire,
opened with $158 million, and earned $424
million in the United States and $865 million
worldwide, becoming the highest-grossing film
of 2013… but only domestically.
Beyond the U.S., the big winner of 2013 was
the surprise Disney animated smash hit, Frozen.
Frozen opened on a one-theater limited release
in late 2013 with $243,000, but then legged
its way to $400 million domestic and an incredible
$1.27 billion worldwide.
While nobody should ever count out Disney
at the box office, Frozen becoming 2013's
biggest hit worldwide was still surprising,
given it wasn't a sequel, reboot, or remake
— and wasn't based on a popular pre-existing
property, either.
From a wider perspective, 2013 proved that
the global box office was more important than
ever, as the biggest domestic hit didn't actually
become the biggest hit worldwide a trend that
would continue in the years ahead.
For decades, audiences' movie-going diets
have been fattened by sequels, reboots, and
remakes.
Given this movie-going landscape, American
Sniper was a genuine milestone in 2014.
It was the first original property since 2011
to top the domestic box office, and the only
movie this century to do so that wasn't a
big-budget, CG-infused blockbuster.
This achievement is all the more impressive
considering the movie was also given an R
rating.
That said, American Sniper's status as "2014's
biggest movie" is a bit of a misnomer, since
it actually made most of its money in 2015.
The movie first opened in limited release
in December 2014, making a little more than
$633,000 in just four theaters.
It opened wide in January 2015 with an incredible
$92 million, and continued to leg it out to
a $350 million domestic haul.
And while American Sniper was the number one
hit domestically, its total worldwide take
didn't even secure it a spot in the top ten.
The year's biggest worldwide hit was, unsurprisingly,
a franchise picture Transformers: Age of Extinction.
The fourth film in the Transformers series
made a so-so $245 million domestically, but
it was big business overseas, with a total
worldwide take of just a little more than
$1.1 billion.
American Sniper may have been an historic
achievement stateside, but worldwide, Chris
Kyle couldn't top the bots.
Disney purchased LucasFilm in 2012 for $4
billion, and they didn't do it just to re-release
the Star Wars Holiday Special on Blu-ray.
No, the Mouse House was on a serious mission:
to resurrect the beloved franchise from a
galaxy far, far away.
Inevitably, Star Wars: The Force Awakens became
one of the most anticipated films of the century.
Fans had waited decades to see what happened
to Han, Luke, Leia, and the gang after the
Empire had fallen in 1983's Return of the
Jedi.
This would be the first Star Wars film in
10 years too, as well as the first that wasn't
a prequel in 32 years.
It'd also be the first ever that wasn't led
by series creator George Lucas.
While the original Star Wars helped invent
the summer movie season, this would be the
first film in the franchise to open during
the holiday season.
This turned out to be a brilliant move.
The Force Awakens opened like a summer blockbuster
with a then-record $247 million, but had the
legs of a holiday release.
By the end of its run, the movie had earned
$936 million stateside to become not only
the number one domestic release of 2015, but
the then-biggest domestic hit of all time.
The Force was strong overseas, too, as the
film earned just over $2 billion globally,
making it the biggest hit worldwide of 2015.
Almost inevitably, Disney won 2016 too, with
the biggest box office hit both domestically
and worldwide though those were different
movies.
Captain America: Civil War kicked things off,
opening in the spring of 2016 and pitting
Cap against Iron Man in a franchise-shaking
fight to the death.
Adding Robert Downey Jr.'s Tony Stark to the
movie proved to be a big boon to the film's
box office, as Civil War opened to $179 million,
nearly twice as much as its predecessor, The
Winter Soldier.
The movie managed a massive $408 million domestic
gross, and more importantly, made a grand
total of $1.15 billion quickly becoming the
biggest global box office hit of 2016.
After Star Wars: The Force Awakens' historic
run during the 2015 holiday season, Disney
wisely chose to release Rogue One: A Star
Wars Story in December 2016.
Rogue One was the first Star Wars movie that
wasn't part of the main Skywalker Saga, but
moviegoers were nonetheless ravenous for more.
The movie opened to $155 million, on its way
to a $532 million domestic take, and just
over $1 billion worldwide, making it the biggest
domestic hit of 2016 and number two worldwide.
The battle for box office supremacy was no
longer a fight between rival studios; it was
a fight between rival Disney properties.
"I've got a bad feeling about this."
Before the year even began, the biggest box
office hit of 2017 was practically a given:
Star Wars: The Last Jedi.
It was just a matter of how much money Rian
Johnson's followup to The Force Awakens would
make.
That said, 2017 featured strong performances
from several other films.
Disney's live-action Beauty and the Beast
remake opened in the spring, earning $504
million domestically and $1.26 billion worldwide.
The Fate of the Furious opened in the summer,
earning a respectable $226 million domestically
but making an insane $1.2 billion worldwide,
becoming the year's biggest international
hit by a pretty sizable margin.
You can't stop destiny though, and Star Wars
was destined to dominate.
"Not now [...]"
The Last Jedi opened during the 2017 holiday
season with $220 million less than its predecessor,
but that wasn't too surprising given it wasn't
preceded by decades of pent-up demand.
It's possible that a divided response from
moviegoers and a stronger-than-expected performance
from Jumanji: Welcome to the Jungle didn't
exactly help, either.
But the film made $620 million domestically
and $1.3 billion worldwide, making it easily
the biggest hit of the year.
And that's not so bad, is it?
The only Star Wars movie released in 2018 somehow managed to tank at the box office,
so it soon became pretty obvious that a Marvel
movie would take the year's top spot.
However, the Marvel movie that won the day
domestically was a bit of a surprise.
Black Panther opened in February, a season
not typically known for blockbuster releases,
and rode a wave of awesome reviews and positive
sentiment to score a mammoth $202 million
on its opening weekend.
Black Panther wasn't a one-weekend wonder
either, as it continued to leg it out, earning
a historic $700 million domestically and $1.3
billion worldwide.
Black Panther was the biggest domestic hit
of 2018 and is one of only a handful of movies
ever to earn more than $700 million at the
domestic box office.
But while that movie was an historic surprise,
the biggest worldwide earner was a given.
Avengers: Infinity War was the beginning of
the sort-of-end for the most successful franchise
of all time, bringing together a range of
characters from across the entire MCU.
With anticipation at a fever pitch, Infinity
War set the then-opening weekend record with
$257 million.
The movie couldn't quite match Black Panther's
runaway success at the domestic box office,
though it still earned a mammoth $678 million
stateside.
And with a global take of just over $2 billion,
it was the biggest hit of the year worldwide
by far.
After Infinity War's shocking cliffhanger
ending, Disney made a shrewd decision with
the marketing for the movie's follow-up.
Fans didn't even know the film's title until
a few months before its release, and the trailers
revealed practically nothing about the story
only that the story's remaining heroes would
do "whatever it takes" to stop Thanos.
"I am inevitable."
This mysterious marketing campaign paid off
in spades.
While it was set in stone that Avengers: Endgame
would break records, not even the most optimistic
observers could predict that the movie would
obliterate the opening weekend record set
by its predecessor, earning $357 million domestically,
and more than $1.2 billion worldwide.
A midsummer expansion propelled Endgame's
final gross to $858 million domestically and
an incredible $2.79 billion worldwide.
Its combined total makes it not only the biggest
hit of 2019 stateside and worldwide, but the
highest-grossing film of all time, too.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.